Um,
how do I buy one today is how our grade honors.
You have a hurt eminence [inaudible] Kosho also known as the Mala visiting
Google and giving us a talk.
Oh,
women's social role.
Um,
the Amala was born in eastern Tibet.
She found it to India in 1959 with her family and moved to the United States a
year later where she helped her husband on the phone,
the sunshine on a story.
You have a tobacco,
but it is on you.
1980s in addition to taking a full time job and you single find sons,
she took all necessary trainings to become a qualified,
a spiritual teacher.
She is also actively engaged in educating younger generations.
I don't of [inaudible] and it has found it a few times,
centers in North America,
um,
as our featured in the bloke with any power.
And Amala is considered one of the most influential female Buddhist masters in
the word.
So it's a great honor for us.
Do you have Donna here and I give her her talk?
Yes,
please.
And in their Tibetan language,
it means as score screenings.
The good afternoon everyone.
Greetings from Seattle.
Well,
I would like to start by thanking all of the organizers and especially my friend
Jessica Hawaii for inviting me here.
Come here to talk about social role of the Tibet and the woman.
I must say that I am honored and humbled to be a dog person,
sort of the sexy blend and uh,
and they'll very active young minds.
I am Tibetan old woman Hartej Sheena was born in east Tibet and,
uh,
strong background at the Buddhism and later I married such a Dalton Rumba chair
in psychiatry.
And,
uh,
as many of you know,
we have a new Tibet days,
four set of Tibetan Buddhism and the suitcase case for one of them,
which we'll call it new Mapa Guy,
Cuba psychopathy and get Luba.
And the second dodge in Roma,
Chez father was the door 48,
uh,
thrown holder in the second Tibet.
So I married,
lived in a palace with many 70 Sarah Hunt and uh,
then 90,
59,
uh,
we were forced to out to exile from Tibet,
lacquer,
all other Tibetans.
So then we lived in India the short for yet,
but then University of Washington abroad us to research,
uh,
teach you reach this research too.
My husband Dartin Dodgy Cha as well as my anchor for the three years grant.
So since we cannot go back to bed because the
skeleton when it's under the,
uh,
Chinese,
so we,
uh,
emigrate to the states in United State.
So then I was working like any,
like any of you like working hard,
raising a lot.
He mentioned,
now I mentioned that,
uh,
five children to put in school,
so forth.
So I try to keep up with the growing change in the modern world and all its
modern gadgets and main cities.
I haven't seen much experience much in over 80 years that I have lived.
Today.
I speak to you through my experience as a woman and especially as a wife,
mother,
grandmother and great grandmother and the Tibet and the woman and Tibet would,
does petitioner.
So very little was knowing to the words of Tibet to the woman.
And 10.
We lost our country in 1959
since then,
large number of us lived,
um,
have lived to in egg assign various countries.
We have learned to adapt to the culture and the language or whatever country we
found ourselves Livia however no mantra way we are and no matter what challenge
life threw at us,
we are strong as people and Chandra
Tibetan culture is filled with a strong feminine roles and the model.
So specially like Tibetans always decided a major things and from mother
as we are deeply spiritual people,
very often our roles are the female deities.
We have [inaudible] the mother of goddess who do you got it as all her children
and guiding at protecting us and taking care of which Tibet and we called the
drama,
which is savior.
She made a vow to save all sentient beings from the suffering and be reborn in
female form and our life men now all the lifetime we have with snitch.
But I was also given us goddess who gives a long life.
One of the most powerful protective deity is the female deity,
which we call a bandaid humble.
Who is the,
also predicted it as wrathful foam and created and fear all
and names like Machiel have Jane and famous female protector of the 11th century
who initiated the Sobel practices of the spiritual development.
And he shits all your condo IISHA soldier who help us this desperate and the
Buddhism in Tibet are and
help to us.
The great reverence
woman are not very active in the political field.
Before we lost our country,
there have been many Tibetan,
the woman who were involved in the politics of the,
uh,
regional governors,
but to such a permanent was not a soul invisible in a central administrator.
But,
um,
for example,
like he would call up and book Zombie all over color.
Uh,
if the leaders,
kings and the husband had died or woman take over the,
for example,
like a queen of the gay or region in east Tibet rule our region until her young
son attended by a majority queen's Hall Hummel,
who was very popular leader and did much the promoted literacy and learning
during the whole regent.
There was other Tibetan,
the woman who played a prominent rules in tribes,
especially in the eastern Tibet.
Tibet.
Women have always had a strong rules of a family and all of harmony.
If they have some big decisions and always make by mother many household,
uh,
rude by a matriarchs
and old Tibetan woman,
or let's see,
matriarchs.
Okay.
And then automate the woman,
my verse and business owners,
nomads and a farmers.
In fact,
it was not uncommon for the Tibet woman to be married.
The tool has been,
oh three husbands as same time and most drag their brothers though living in
harmonious and the same household.
Oh,
of course.
It was for the particle purpose of keeping the land and the divided and the such
a household as woman would always one who rules in the roots and roofed
a large number about Tibet.
The woman,
yeah,
put full percent become nuns and also a Buddhist nuns.
The nunneries war place to all lonely.
And a woman could put Shui and the educated,
which was not really available for the young girls.
In fact,
both man and woman,
and a tone to monasteries.
And the nunneries for education as these instructions,
we're the sole providers of education in the old days.
Okay.
Secular education was not widespread at the same time.
Like my time.
Okay.
This is kind of a silly problem city.
I tell you something.
I remember when my aunt,
my aunt was nunnery 11 nunnery.
I visited them.
Nanda you quite often.
I enjoy this very much with the nuns.
They have a beautiful voice with the chanting in the singing and I will try to
make it,
you know like way or non close and the cover mine here for their towel and I
enjoy it very much.
Had to go visiting in the [inaudible] but I never wanted pay none.
The reason why as he,
you know an a Tibetan no on what pod [inaudible] east,
west Central,
all all over to bend and girls,
a woman's where they were all kind of a jewelries covered with the hair and head
dresses.
So I always say,
see they're so beautiful.
They,
you know,
because the Tibetans and my time at that time,
we don't have banking system.
And the jewel is his,
was the acid in the family and the men may have a horses or raffles or salts
does that's we have.
So this is like silly and said,
you know,
I never wanted it to be nine because again,
not a way of jewelries.
That was it today.
When I think back,
it was silly.
So,
so we're losing our country and living in exile Tibetan woman have played very
cool,
sure rule and preserving our culture and tradition in a foreign lands like
myself.
Okay.
Now in exile Tibetan a woman are well represented in a politic of fields and
members of parliament ministers and hold position of power of decision making in
the various administrative and offices
today to when woman are doctors,
nurses,
teachers,
lawyers,
business owners,
artists and other occupation.
Like,
oh,
I was toiling today.
There's an a Google,
I'm sure you have thousand,
maybe 10,000 days to Tibet.
The woman are working here.
So that was,
you know,
I was very happy to know that.
So this is what,
um,
you know,
to when a woman's are today,
two can do it.
So to when people are generally knowing as a peaceful people due to our
spiritual practice of generating loving kindness and compassion for all beings,
we strive to feel great compassion for others as the does for ourself
in order to help the more motive.
As in this practice,
we are talked at the early age regarding all the sentient beings as the one's
own mother.
Yeah.
A mother is regarded as a compassionate one who phone nine months carries child
within her womb and who continue to love and nurture her children well and to
become a dot.
So this is a,
we have to think more.
A mother is the
publication of loving kindness and compassion.
So in our culture and the mother is regarded with great reverence as life force
and nurture.
So we also things mother protects the child until I get eight,
eight years old,
even the protectors from the mother's shadow protect the child.
So therefore women are treated with great respect and are equal partner in
their homes.
So,
and the Tibetan also the now the exile before exile,
you know,
Japan is lucky,
you know all the culture like we have heard it,
you know,
not Tibetan woman exile and the live too many countries,
specialty Levine,
ice skating,
many thousands and first when we came,
we don't have an education background as well as the language problem.
So many Japan woman are worked in a nanny's housekeeping and so forth.
So I have heard that Tibetan women are very much a demand as nannies and
caregivers for both young and old people because they have compassion and talk
to the,
when they're young it is their kindness and compassion and that makes them
provide the best to carry and the love even for those that are not their own
blood,
uh,
or race.
Today,
working mothers are truly superhuman in their abilities to more to task between
their work environment and their home front.
However,
women are still woman and bring warmth and softness and whatever.
And whenever they are doing
now in Tibet,
now in the Tibetan families,
you know,
beef whole
mini part of in Asia and the Tibet,
it's always the window.
How many have a child,
they always like to have boy select many pots in the war to be fought.
Now in the Tibetan family,
when the girls was born,
the praying parents express grief,
joy,
and they will have someone who would look after them after they get old.
So the,
you know,
time changes.
So to begin a woman like the woman as around the world have faced a challenge
due to the Genta bias.
However,
we have very compassionate spiritual leader.
His Holiness,
the Dalai Lama threw his mini initiative.
His wholeness has encouraged Tibet,
the woman to be part of governance and social ICAN,
ICAN.
He,
he kinda make growth in the exile.
Even recently in the 90,
uh,
2016 last year,
he's holding is confirmed Ashima degree and the 29th in south of India,
which is first in our history of Tibet and it abandoned people.
[inaudible] my degree is [inaudible] a men,
uh,
compatible to the direction and the philosophy.
And the degree is confound after 21 years of rigorous study of five main
Buddhist tabs,
this is the step forward in the equal right.
And the Tibet in the woman as the education is the key to changing and
development.
I would like to invasion to feature we women are equal partner in the all the
field of life in the workforce.
I would love to see women be equally
compensated for her time and effort.
I hope this that they will come to time when women are not Fred to go way they
want and what they want to do.
Okay.
At the home,
a woman is the daughter,
sister,
mother,
wife.
Hold on.
Should it be the safe even from the all the trade and the challenge of the
outside world,
if they are round in the home,
unfortunately the world is not perfect place and a woman well continue to face
discrimination at the work abuse at home
and the disparity due to the Yantra.
It is true that even today
there are countries where the woman out treated tweeted little better than
cattle.
However,
we can still strive to change the plight of women all over.
If woman are United in the common cause,
if they are afraid,
tell other women,
okay,
we need to speak openly.
If you are abused,
tells other women.
If you are a happy Lee,
increase it by sharing,
uh,
sharing your happiness.
If you are sad like it,
by sharing your story with someone.
We live in an age of social media,
which is powerful tools.
All of you now.
So solve yourself to being a woman and embarrass other woman,
to farm a strong circle of support when a woman can't be here,
great pain like woman,
the one who brings the child.
I mean,
I have to go to through the all pains and not me,
but men have you realize how to share what pains going through one man,
okay?
And come out.
But if even these painful come out to shiny,
in the end,
we are mother,
wife,
daughter,
and we are strong.
If we should have more female leaders in the world,
we would be more peaceful place and woman have the innate quality of patient and
compassion and in the war and the war word,
not that I Atara we should feel honored and proud to be born in a woman and we
can do much as woman of the knowledge and compassion.
Tibetan woman are always strong and we remain a strong.
And since our exposure to the outside world,
we are inspired by women in the west who stand shoulder to shoulder with men
while still holding down the fort at home.
I am inspired to outrigger woman,
African American woman who made sure their voice or hood in the day movement and
the civil right.
I paid homage to all the great women who have come before us and the struggle
with the restraint of time and uh,
prejudice and who have made the path easier for us now follow.
So this is part of what our Tibet in the woman,
how,
wait,
hello.
How is still how our saw and if you have any question.
Thank you Donna for [inaudible] in the spring talk.
So I have to take this chance to,
to,
to ask you the first classroom,
I suggest the mentioned that,
uh,
you think,
women should take a more leadership role in the word in the modern world.
And so I wonder what kind of a Buddhist teachings can help women to become more
common than tomorrow?
Capable for taking the leadership?
Well,
Lord,
Buddha,
Shakyamuni as the teachers to us,
no Genera woman made any age,
any race is equally,
we can be enlightened and equally,
but it's,
uh,
the award is the [inaudible] and the misunderstanding and things it takes
getting better.
But I still think women should be strong and they shouldn't be subs,
you know,
how to sell on.
You have owned the courage and uh,
and think that we are happy a Doobie born with this.
I knew we wanted to help with whatever can
and did I make,
so you'll know yourself,
don't try to lower down to make think of we all equal.
And the teaching says all the ego is like that.
The uh,
uh,
the petitioner or Tibetans monks or lamas or all the petitioner and equally in
lighting.
What did they do?
The right path,
right route is most important to see some motivation.
Yeah.
Thank you.
And also I'm a particular interest in Arabia,
Linda Edge,
because I know that so far all the throwing holders have satellite centers have
been male members of [inaudible] family.
I wonder if in the future maybe a female member cows,
I'll be a leader.
Do you think that's possible?
Very good.
Good question.
Just like I mentioned it earlier in the Tibetan Buddhism as four set and what
doesn't.
And like those all four sets,
many have a Dorian conditions,
which is just like you already know.
These are like Dalai Lama is like 1413 reincarnated.
And so it's come up,
I like 17 reincarnated and does unluck psychopaths,
psychopaths or region in a descended from celestial realm.
I knew a person from celestial realm and married with the human and the produce
to not children.
And that's why they need to carry on these,
the no reincarnation father to son.
And so this is a,
it's a different than reincarnation.
And so other lamas recognize and condition like we all,
we all are somebodies England,
Asia.
Anyway,
so that unlike the [inaudible] lineage and then,
uh,
mentioned it.
Yes.
It's a true up to my time is always the male system.
And I heard a lot of psych.
Yeah.
Historic,
uh,
when the alarm I'm married and don't have a son and then the maybes have,
don't marry second a toad wife and chill brain son.
And so I remember myself when I got married with my husband,
my father in law to give a blessing with name change legs.
It also says bring Sun.
So huck why's that?
But today's different,
but they have,
if they have a daughter,
daughter,
is he equally teach psych?
Yeah.
Any teaching,
but daughter's son is not be the [inaudible] care lineage,
but it's not the same.
It's mail.
So that's a different,
but it's just the [inaudible] is the always the lady to father to son when they
passed away,
they way you pray to be born.
The same.
How many this is up to over a thousand,
maybe close to thousand years.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I understand.
This is a tradition and uh,
yeah,
I think there are a lot of,
I like it,
a female members of the family and they live very good to practitioners that
probably even though they are not the throwing a holder of [inaudible] role is
to help grow the time on teaching and also help with the family.
Uh,
how,
how would the community,
yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
So no,
sit and take some questions from the audience.
I a Buddhist,
my husband always say you do a chanting and uh,
reciting Mantras,
just suture and you're also making lots of donation.
And how would that,
oh,
the things that you did.
Um,
Ben,
the fair,
me and our family.
This is my first question.
That is good.
Yes.
If we are connected,
for example,
my cell phone example,
I have a lot of friends and students who are kind of the light on me and ask me
and I will do this sincerely to topology to help whatever they need and the
healer,
their suffering.
And this is the,
yes,
you cannot,
like I mentioned yesterday,
there's the what the donee and the giving,
the taking.
That's why if you pray your husband,
will it help?
Yes.
Even he doesn't believe in Buddhism.
There's always some blessing there.
And my second question is,
uh,
would you please share,
um,
yeah,
wisdom about emptiness.
So that way I can share with you Kim,
that is a big question.
Emptiness is we talk a lot,
I'm emptiness,
but there's always the essence.
There is everything.
Phenomena is like emptiness,
never the same.
It's changing,
changing salons.
But the essence is there too.
Why you called?
Um,
uh,
part of your life is he born and every teen is never the same.
It's just implemented.
But uh,
same time,
this essence there.
So that's the big cause.
You but a few practice Buddhism you will learn if each of us has some wisdom to
leading us.
If you really follow that too,
to concentrate,
do some meditation,
then we'll show that what to do next.
But it just are talking emptiness.
Emptiness means everything.
Nobody knew what you miss.
It is elite team emptiness,
this essence of,
and my second,
a separate question.
This us a lay practitioner,
especially for a woman,
how to balance their family life.
And um,
also practice Buddha Dharma.
Thank you,
dawn.
I usually call doctor might use a daily life.
Those are the Lama's monks and nuns.
They have nunnery monetary this day.
They're supported and they do it all a prey.
But the late protection as us like husband,
why would have to raise children,
go to school,
work and so forth every day.
Your life just to,
you'll know it in the Tibetan Buddhists and will also say is human lives.
How precious,
most precious in the life.
Which means we have an opportunity,
we can do things,
we have a physically,
we have everything round,
especially the US.
I knew all the teachers and teachings and a living,
everything.
Freedom.
Okay.
So since you get up in the morning,
you should be happy.
Oh,
I'm happy.
I'm still alive.
I wanted to do something for good myself and my family and extended for my
neighbors whole world.
And this is thinking that's the positive thinking,
positive attitude and that helps a lead through the day is happy and that is
part of your Dharma practice.
Parlay petitioner.
But everything you do,
you think something you do dried and helping others with from sincerely.
That's why we say it has to come from a heart.
You wanted to help somebody and give them,
maybe I get something back.
Don't think that you'll have to do and conditioner walk.
Unconditional love.
How you do your own children.
I see.
So this is what I help.
It does.
So the you can never see or you know,
any lay people what can be enlightened if did have her at the right path.
Yes.
Always good.
It doesn't matter.
Any race,
it doesn't matter.
I said I had to have a good heart.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Hi.
I have one question,
uh,
out.
What's the most of the challenge you'll fishing?
Uh,
you think when you are flat from a debate.
That is my first question.
I mean the most of the challenging.
You think you how do you have challenges?
Thing?
Yeah.
I don't recall.
I done tremendous things,
but I feel I'm good.
I haven't done something in this life.
So benefit others,
tried to teach something positive and raised.
Uh,
and my family and try to go to teaching wherever I can,
whatever I can do.
And then I lived with this,
I'm 84 years old.
I still maybe feel more years,
who knows?
And so I always tanking and myself,
I'm very happy and can do this.
Thank you.
Hi.
Thank you very much for come and give the talk.
Um,
one question I have is uh,
you mentioned 4% of Tibet and women become nuns and they are nunneries in Tibet.
Uh,
is that still the case now?
There are still quite some nunneries in Tibet or this is in the old age before
you left Tibet?
Yes.
I just recently visited in the Tibet last month and I offered support many
nunneries and those lands as a summer Landry's only problem.
There is a limit.
You can have so many each Landry before anybody who wish to go.
But now this,
each nunnery has a lot,
so many nights we have in the router Satya and his two nunneries I visited one
is like 250,
almost one is like last time I visited only a 25.
Now it's 37.
But they have limited,
they have to get past kind of passport from government to get in certain things.
Otherwise,
yes they are nunneries and this and answer very good.
Partitioners and of course anonymous in India and Tibet.
And they will have a debate like monks and they do vary.
And I also heard that some people are patrons who wonder,
ask,
pray for Montessori or nunneries and they like to do nannies because Nancy,
the the and the do until prayed done and monks and maybe not choice,
some will get up and walk out.
So anyway,
these are very good.
And then old Nance,
like my time before,
they are still nuns.
I heard in still in the cave to practicing all their life.
But like I said,
it's a,
before the Tibetans came out in exile and warming and not out because man,
it Ma Lama's monks tacos or so many of the women are not really even petitioner.
They do the to the uh,
do their own practice.
Not so much going around the teachings,
but now they are.
Yes.
Uh,
so the teachers are,
the nunneries are nuns.
So there's no,
like a male Llama teachers at the nunneries?
Um,
I would say most languages have a dog.
Just none.
I bet to know I've witnessed what I call,
but some llamas,
um,
who are qualified llamas and uh,
Cambos or took,
who's can't go give a teaching certain Marianna teaching so they can practice.
But like our mind and our practice,
we have to have received a certain teachers without receiving transmission and
teachings.
We cannot practice.
So the,
yes,
the male lamaze go there,
teach and not live with nuts.
Okay.
So in general,
the Buddhism teaching in a nunnery,
are they very similar to the Buddhist institute?
Where monastery for a monks or,
uh,
anything special,
for nunneries we're maybe not as stringent as the monks are.
Your main Tenet,
the teachings and the bad and the India and those places?
Uh,
yeah,
I mean,
just compare the nunneries and in a monastery for monks,
are these very simple,
yes,
they are very similar.
And,
uh,
even now,
or nuns have a more like I just mentioned,
uh,
his whole legs get vacation Ma degree,
which is equally is uh,
you know,
[inaudible] which is a doctorate degree.
And this is just first time happened in Tibet history.
So Nancy doing debates announced to all of what the monks I teach.
Yes,
he could.
Yesterday you mentioned about you,
it's our phone to Ben and climbed the Himalaya.
Just imagine that it is still very difficult for nowadays.
So would you please share your insight?
How come you can be so strong?
I can get leading by two point Jim and I at that guide me and help me,
uh,
like all other people who are two guiding from the torch him.
But it's a true and when I came out from Tibet with three children,
youngest one is just about year old is still diaper on and crossing the
Himalayas.
And you wasn't easy,
but we left country because we don't want to give up Dharma.
That's why we left.
And then like I said,
it,
uh,
sometime my life,
I lived in the palace in Psychia.
I raised by my wonderful family is too bad.
I lived in this,
again,
married with the head with the [inaudible] and liver doing palace and then cross
mountain and the refugee camps and then came here.
Uh,
Leo bought from a Rockefeller Foundation for three years.
Grant I ever,
since we cannot go back.
So here I had to do,
I wrote his book,
first book,
I can get it and I give the first book to the His Holiness Dalai Lama.
And he was very happy and he was saying that this is very good because it gives
us courage.
You pour the other Tibetan woman because you are in Tibet,
your first lady and hear your American seven,
which is true
mother,
grandma,
everything.
I only like working for Tibet.
No American.
Yes.
So that's why now on the sensor,
I've tired.
He tired.
I know I tried it.
I do much is practice myself and it helped the others teaching not just women,
men,
anybody who needs in my own experience,
my Sherry.
I also grateful lots of men who supports us.
Thank you.
I'm only talking today one,
but man,
a wonderful helper.
Lotta things.
Yes.
With how the lag I had that I even said there's no men if a days,
no woman as equally,
but he wanders remain.
Did he wound with a woman too can help the all the beans.
Thank you for more.
And my last question is,
there's recently,
there's a movie called wonder woman here.
I feel that I was so attached by the,
the uh,
wonder woman's compassion.
And so when I saw yesterday's topic Dakini power,
is there any special training for us to female first female to like have
received some kind of special training and to become more powerful to help the
sanction pain because that is so beautiful.
What kind of power?
Just,
I hadn't,
I only just recalled it.
The spiritual and the,
you'll have to,
in a Tibetan Buddhism,
you cannot just pick a book that he eat.
All you can say,
I'm lots of my western,
the street in will sometimes say I'm Buddhist.
Many years I've read so many books,
I went to lots of classes.
But that doesn't mean to your Buddhist.
In the Buddhism I go,
it's necessary.
You'll have to receive the refugee vow,
which is the some commitment there.
And after you receive that,
then if the teacher and the student have commendment teacher triple gem with
protect you,
guide you and your students followed that guidance.
But finding teacher is the very hard.
Today I would say there's so many young teachers allow mas and all kinds of,
I don't even know that lots of them,
but uh,
you'll have to really find right teacher not just follow their ranking or they
look,
oh,
they dress good.
Oh on it.
Look what the background,
carry the tones,
mission lineage.
Who are their teacher?
Then you'll go for it.
Once you have it,
you don't need them.
Any teachers,
then you'll follow that.
That's it's an um,
Mahayana Buddhism is many teachers,
some are good,
doesn't matter man,
woman,
none or month doesn't matter.
It's just something that answers your question.
Some tea,
you're connected.
Usually we can tell once first we made a few talk.
You kind of tell that and most time into people goes just to look all written so
much about background.
He's holding.
This is the,
all those,
that doesn't means any tea.
You'll have a connection
in the formal.
You thinking about this connection?
I told my husband if I saw like a formal,
I feel connection but my husband wasn't,
that's not um,
is not logic.
So was she at answer him?
That's okay.
All right.
So I have a question about are the software engineering profession.
So in this profession is actually,
uh,
Ms. Bell is of our agenda destiny a lot more guys than girls.
So why do think ar could help to balance the dip gender is because to,
to me it seems very good for,
uh,
for old men to work for them.
Put in the software industry because it's possible to work from home.
She can take care of her family,
who,
when she needs to.
But what,
uh,
what,
what do you see are the obstacles and how can we help attract more women to help
balance this industry?
I think that's what we all know.
Be Nice.
Listen and listen what they want,
how they talk.
You may have is connected.
You'll make any help,
uh,
she made can help you.
You make,
can you help hook?
I saw this is just a gentle is really not much difference on it.
The connection with the your
thinking or your wisdom.
Oh,
you're related or most faint event,
we'll call it the Karma.
We always relate it and it was,
I would always say the two best attains have to be nice with your parents and
the parents have you take care of parents.
They showed him mother,
you will be happy life
and this is the one,
the only way we pray.
We always say early,
pray with all mother and all Sunday bs because we considered this sometime.
I was your mother Mamie the years.
Who knows we are.
There's something like we are here today.
Just there's some collected I believe every time I believe it will have somebody
to closer and talking.
I'll feel,
and this is some lifetime we had some condition.
Yes.
So it's most important patient and especially woman.
Need a patient.
Thank you.
Yeah.
A very sensitive women are more sensitive so you give a patient then you'll
always find the right path through your wisdom.
Okay.
I want to ask the last question.
Uh,
so because we were allowed leaving in the west number,
um,
and especially like in coming in as in like,
Oh God,
we have very diverse background,
but he will perform,
will come from different countries in the world.
They have different religions and maybe a lot of our youth is,
they have different beliefs.
I sounds so what do we think's the best way for us to my,
uh,
promote [inaudible] teachings or to help more people in Google or in the
society?
All the religion I respect.
Yeah.
The,
the religion spiritually,
they day helping the all bs,
whatever they need.
It's always,
but what we need is to everything.
Uh,
today's alive.
Um,
we just too fast.
Everything you,
oh,
you'll have to have that new,
you don't need it as so slow down tank.
Do I really need this?
Uh,
things,
materials too much.
And also,
and when you have a something,
somebody says something you didn't like it here,
you just patient listen,
not answer right away.
So this kind of helping for calmness and communication and the peaceful the
world.
So this is because it's like I mentioned yesterday,
some people have one or you did again,
another one.
If you'll help him,
that one car,
I need better car.
She's like iPhone,
everything.
It's too much.
These,
if you know how to work,
that might be helpful.
Ward is lots of things.
For example,
I have iPhone.
I only know how to,
we chat or to call is has fancy things,
but I don't know.
So why I need that.
So something you really,
sometime you don't need.
Yes sir.
Yes.
You'll have one car,
unit,
second car.
You cannot drive two cars and time.
So it's just slow down and do leisure.
Meditation.
Doesn't have to be Buddhist.
Just little bit down to the patient talking anything.
Just think more than two.
I think this is the leads to easier and peace for everyone.
Thank you so much.
Thank you again for your inspiring talking to you.
Otherwise,
and also thank you for the hosting team and all the audience for your time.
Thank you.